hey guys today i'm going to show you how
to get the safari for webkit on any
operating system this will work on
anything that i know of except for linux
so here we go
first we're going to open any web
browser
i'm going to use safari just for the
purpose of this video
and page this is google and i'm going to
search in
safari
webkit
and the first link will be webkit.org
the open source project click on that
link it'll start to load
and soon enough we have
a download link right here
um this is where we download the nightly
builds basically the supply 4 webkit is
just tiny bug fixes that give safari the
boost it needs to be
just that almost perfect web browser
it's extremely fast already click
download nightly builds and it'll bring
you to
a page where you can choose your
operating system mac os 10 or windows
whether it's vista xp 95 98 whatever you
might have
and click on
um this is a 22 megabyte download for
windows
20 makes for vista or for os 10
and
once you have it
you will
in your start menu
if you search webkit hopefully you can
see this in hd
if you search webkit it'll search and
you will see
all these things what you want to do is
hit
run nightly webkit
right click it and run it as an
administrator
and
i already have this saved right here i
changed the icon and everything and i
named it what so when i click it it goes
through this whole and prop prompt
uh dialogue it lasts about five seconds
but i think it's worth the wait
now the original safari every time you
ran the acid three test every single
time you ran the browser acid 3 test you
got a 75 out of 100
which is really bad
and the leak test would always fail
and that was a problem with one of
safari's little bugs so now if i were to
type in acid 3
and click on after 3 test
there you go
safari 4 webkit
passes the acid 3 test with a 100 out of
100
so i highly recommend you go ahead to
google and search
um
webkit and webkit.org
open up the page and download that
nightly build it makes safari that much
faster see how fast it takes to open up
youtube and another thing if you have
icons for your um favorites look as i
roll down here it'll open up what the
icon was next to it so that's pretty
cool
and i had a few there
so i think it's pretty cool um it's just
a sweet sweet web browser right now and
it's extremely fast how low fast it
buffers let's see google maps
done
how fast was that it's crazy
um so i really really recommend this to
anyone who's looking for the fastest
browser on windows um
i already showed you a tutorial on how
to make firefox faster well that that i
guess will be my tutorial on how to make
uh safari faster um how i got this icon
was the right i first i downloaded this
image uh i like the image i downloaded
it then i right click uh what it was
before
hit icon settings
and just uh find where you saved the
image click on that
um and that will be what the icon is and
it's just a png image nice high
resolution image i like it hit ok
and i renamed it webkit
by typing it in right here so
that's how you get the safari for webkit
guys look open up the original safari
and type acid 3
and you will get
this big red icon here link test failed
and 75 out of 100 every single time
without fail
but should you open safari
for webkit you'll get decent long
dialogue but i think it's worth it um
copy files open a bunch of resources and
things
then it'll actually buffer the browser
itself
type in acid 3 and just to show you i'm
not joking one more time
100 out of 100 baby i love this so um go
ahead and download that to make your
internet browsing experience that much
faster uh subscribe peace